hey everybody what is going on i am back
talking about leica m mount lenses
but not necessarily like a lenses even
though i just acquired this 50 sumicron
ridgid uh version 2
for my leica mp a la carte camera i
absolutely love this lens it is
beautiful it is clean um it was serviced
by kanto camera in japan so for those
who know you know um and i just picked
this up from rice while photography
who's my go-to for a lot of vintage
lenses and secondhand lenses anyway
they've been kind enough to also loan me
these um voigtlander lenses to talk
about today the 50 f2 apolanthar and the
35f2 apolanthar and we're going to focus
on the 35 a little bit more on this
review because
this is a very um
special lens in the sense that leica has
just released their 35 f2 summicron oppo
variant recently
which has got a lot of people excited
and the price point is about
10 to 12 times of this lens
but those who have tried this lens are
very impressed
how good is this lens is it worth
considering even though it's 12 times
less can it even get close to the leica
well let's talk about the 35 f2 apple
lantar from voightlander
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if you leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.com
so before we begin i do want to let you
guys know we're not paid or sponsored
for this video these are my thoughts and
my thoughts only now rice ball
photography as i mentioned provided the
lenses for review but that is it anyway
let's talk about the design of the 35 f2
oppo lanthar now in regards to the 50 f2
these lenses are relatively the same the
only difference you're going to notice
of course is the 35 is slightly taller
oddly enough you think 35 millimeter
would be shorter than 50 but no
not in this case um but let's talk about
the outside of it now it has that
scalped focus ring that we've seen on a
lot of voigtlander lenses as of late the
51.2 knockdown the uh 41.2 and also
we're seeing it here on the oppo lantar
lenses and this design element if i'm
not mistaken derives from
this 50 summer crown rigid right here
now that wasn't planned to bring this
here to show you the design similarities
but
it's here and also we're seeing a lot of
the leica limited edition lenses also
come over with this scalloped uh focus
ring but moving on to the voigtlanders
here the build quality on this lens is
fantastic it feels solid nothing on this
feels inexpensive whatsoever comes in at
304 grams so it's got some weight to it
not heavy but it's not light it feels
substantial
we've got red markings and white
markings the focus ring is smooth as
butter it feels fantastic and you have a
clickable aperture ring here listen to
this
oh i love a clickable aperture ring you
know some of these lens companies are
just going with uh you know non-click
version no
if you're making a photography lens it
has to click in my personal opinion
video
de-click
photography
click
it just feels better you know what i
mean but moving to the front of the lens
here we have this chrome or
shiny metal front element to it which
i'm not a big fan of to be honest with
you and the reason i'm not a fan of it
is because
if you're mounting this to a leica
camera because it's an m-mount lens but
black it doesn't make a chrome
shiny chrome camera there's no shiny
chrome elements on it everything is
matte
silver or it's brushed silver so
i kind of wish voilander would just
stick with the sony e-mount variant
where it's all black and bring that over
into the leica mount variant but
it is what it is lens is made in japan
it says so right on the lens which is a
very very good thing because nowadays uh
there are some lens companies out there
that making their uh products in other
countries it's not a bad thing it's just
something to take note of i mean this
lens just feels fantastic now it's not a
bulging lens in terms of its um the
width of it actually feels very uh
narrow for what it is and of course it's
an f2 versus a 1.2 1.2 will require a
little bit more glass
there's a lot of things moving inside of
that to get that wide open aperture so
of course it will be a little bit more
compact at f2 moving to the front of it
though you do have that apple lanthar
design element these three stripes red
green and blue
um then you have 35 f2 a voigtlander on
it and it is very clean very modern
looks great glass looks fantastic on it
as well 49 millimeter for the uh filter
diameter on this as well
but that's pretty much the lens on the
outside of it it just feels and looks
really nice
let's talk about what's inside of this
you have 11 elements in 9 groups you
have a 12 bladed rounded diaphragm on
this so you can get some beautiful bokeh
out of this
you're going to have a double sided
spherical element to this as well and
you also have that apochromatic design
to it which of course
that's what makes this lens very special
it's an apple lens you know as spherical
has been the big thing for lenses for
quite some time but i think oppo is
going to be the next uh version of
lenses we're going to see out there on
the marketplace and i have a feeling
other companies going to come out with
that as well in due time
because it's a selling point as well uh
but that's pretty much it the lens in a
nutshell of course next to the 50. if
you don't say 35 and 50 and you know
don't notice the length you might not
notice which lens you have on the camera
so anyway now like what we're going to
do is we're going to go into lightroom
and i'm going to show you images i've
taken with the 35f2 and i'll show you
images that i've taken on film with the
leica mp camera and the gfx100s to see
how this resolves 100 megapixels can it
do it
let's find out
all right guys we're now in lightroom
taking a look at images from the
voigtlander 35 oppo lanthar now i have
used a variety of cameras for this i've
used the leica sl2 the sigma fpl the
gfx100s
and also a friend of mine danny chiong
has uh taken some shots on his m10 as
well so i'll be showing you some images
with a variety of different cameras give
you an idea of how it renders and of
course the image quality so let's look
at danny's images first here this is
with the m10 this is absolutely
stunning in terms of sharpness
there's no aberration it is a bitingly
sharp lens
i mean look at the lines on this
uh yeah very very impressive no real
vignetting here at all now of course
when you hook it up to the um the m10
and if you want to put a lens profile to
this you're going to alleviate some of
that vignetting but when i'll show you
what it looks like on other cameras you
will see a slight vignetting to it but
for the most part i'm really happy with
this and i like the warmer tones coming
out of the uh apple lantar as well
here's another shot of this
these little bushes here in the ground
and just look at the details we uh zoom
in on this the cigarette butt the greens
the whites i mean
just the amount of detail this lens
captures again absolutely beautiful
yeah it's really really stunning now of
course we'll get to some bokeh in just a
second but let's talk about uh chromatic
aberration in terms of shooting against
backlight because this is where you're
gonna really see the strength of a lens
or not
looking at these uh palm trees here
uh looking here and i really don't see
anything happening on this i mean maybe
some slight green uh fringing here but
easily correctable in lightroom but
very very minimal
again
extremely impressive on that now let's
take a look at an image on the 100s and
with the 100s it's a little bit uh
challenging to manually focus i have to
say the focus peaking on it because of
the lower resolution on the evf you do
struggle a little bit in terms of really
nailing focus but nonetheless we did a
pretty good job it's my friend casey um
and shot a profile shot the beats of
sweat right here the detail
i will say that this lens
does it render a 100 megapixel uh sensor
like the native gfx lenses no it doesn't
i would say this lens really sits well
50 to 60 megapixels this is the sweet
spot above that i think you're gonna see
that this lens really isn't designed to
resolve
at that level but it's still a decent
image no issues at all no aberration
through here um great detail great fall
off i mean it's got a little bit of that
pop to it i'm very happy with that
let's look at another image here
uh this is with the gfx100s now you're
going to see a little bit of the
vignetting happening here now i did
shoot this in a 35 millimeter crop mode
but you will still see some of that
because there is no lens profile to the
voigtlander in that regard and if you
zoom in on this again i missed focus a
bit the focus peaking isn't the best
when you're using a an m lens on the
100s and it also of course the resolving
power of the lens on 100 megapixel
sensor but i mean it's good it's not wow
but it's good but this lens sits at home
as i mentioned before on low resolution
uh sensors case in point let's move on
to the leica sl2
now here's a shot of me uh with leica
sl2 and uh just zooming in on this and
look at the detail i mean the capture
this is a reflection in the mirror
and i'll show you uh before edit and
after edit before edit and after it
again edits our personal preference you
may like or dislike but a lot of detail
right there
very very happy with the output of that
image again look at the detail we're
seeing here the on the honda right here
the metal i mean this is bitingly sharp
the reflections right here if i look on
this
very minimal fringing at all a little
bit of purple right there but honestly
we're splitting hair folks this is a
fantastic lens um and this resolves the
sl2 which is was shot on beautifully
this is where it sits home at on this um
you can see you know just the leather
here on the seat the details
the the stickers here unbelievable
absolutely happy with this now i did do
an edit to this let me show you the
before edit now i did the exposure was a
little bit off on this but of course i
can bring up the shadows because of the
great dynamic range on the sl2
and just look at the details on this i
mean i gotta say
very sharp
handles everything beautifully um
again performs great
on this uh type of camera now let's go
to uh let's just show some bokeh for a
second here
now this is of a bird uh that i captured
it was sitting on this little garbage
bin here and i'm and this one's been
cropped in a bit let me just show the
original image
uh the crop on that so this is the
original crop and i cropped in a little
bit just to kind of get into it because
i couldn't get too close otherwise he
would fly away right
but
again the amount of detail that's
captured here very very useful you see
all the striations and all that just the
details in his legs and his claw and his
claws right there the beak the feathers
i can sharpen this a little bit up and
post if i wanted to but i love the
falloff in the bokeh in the background
it just looks really really nice um it's
got character to it it's not completely
smooth but it's got enough character to
really where it stands out
so i'm pleasantly surprised with that
here's a couple other shots here just to
you know just get these birds flying in
the air just so more of an action shot i
stopped down on this and again you can
see all the details here throughout this
the iso was cranked up a little bit on
this let's give you some of those
numbers on it this was at iso 2500 sl2
is not the best with iso but it did an
admirable job
let's move on to the sigma fpl
now this is a really nice camera
the colors that come out of the sigma
are absolutely beautiful on this
and look at the detail that i'm seeing
right here on this now of course this is
a smaller jpeg i did uh
bring this down just for if i want to
post up on the internet
but yeah this is really really nice look
at this
the amount of texture and detail
in this statue here really impressive
also i gotta say the sigma fpl colors
are beautiful as well case in point
let's look at this one and i really
don't do anything with this because i'm
just using the camera profiles inside of
it and minimal it's minimal what i need
to do because the colors out of this fpl
with this apple length our lens
fantastic
look at the uh
the detail in the middle right here look
how sharp this is coming all the way
through this again i'm manually focusing
this but the sigma fpl focus peaking
works really really well very similar to
the sl2
in that regard
but again the fall off the 3d pop it is
there folks this is really as i
one of the most impressive 35 millimeter
lenses third party for the mount that
i've used to date um here's just another
shot i just thought that was interesting
this red garbage bag and the sea of
green leaves and we just want to zoom in
on this again this is 60 megapixels it
handles this uh resolving power
beautifully on this uh
yeah it's really really nice i'll show
you the before edit
after edit before edit and after edit
just ever so slight
and a little bit of architecture here
the buildings
zoom in on this
sharp
very very sharp again big fan of it uh
so again overall the image quality out
of
this lens is extremely impressive oh by
the way let me show you one little
comparison just in case i will be uh
talking about this lens in another video
down the road but it's the light lens
lab 35 uh
f2 kind of a it's a summa chrono match
of the eight element summicron so let me
show you the voigtlander with a portrait
of my friend casey here we just shot
this in a camera shop
straight out of camera
all i did was literally
bring down the highlights ever so
slightly this was the original i just
brought it down a little bit
manual focus sl2
there you go
and then here is the light lens lab 35
f2
eight element uh homage to the original
summa chron again different lens softer
this is an omaha the original the oppo
lanthar is a more modern rendering lens
but just to kind of give you a
comparison i will be talking about this
in a future video i think down the road
because this lens is stunning in its own
right very different than the apple
lanthar but i gotta say if you're
looking for something modern rendering
look at the detail that you're getting
out of this all right now let's take a
look at some images shot on film with
this lens on my leica mpla cart
this was stopped down a little bit but
you still see the detail
and how well this lens renders of course
film will have a very different look
than digital but it's nice to have this
lens that if you really want to shoot on
film once in a while you have that
liberty and again the details there the
sharpness the fall off the bokeh right
here the background i'm very very
impressed with what i'm seeing out of
this lens and yeah i mean for film
definitely would recommend as well
well as we just saw in lightroom the 35
f2 is a fantastic performing lens this
is uh
this is special you know the 50 f2
apollo antar is a fantastic lens right
this 35 f2 apollontar just really um
it's better
it's just better and
for some of you out there i mean it's
hard to tell by looking at lightroom on
youtube
the subtle differences you might see it
or might not but i can tell the
difference between these two lenses um
as i mentioned in a previous video i
talked about when i did a review on the
50 oppo lanthar you know i said is
around 90 percent of the leica summer
crown oppo variant out there and
you know that lens has been out for a
few years so of course it makes sense
that other lens manufacturers will
you know
they'll acquire the lens they'll you
know reverse engineer it they'll see try
to find that leica magic and they'll try
to get their lenses as close as they can
keeping it reasonably priced
but this is special because
these two lenses i mean the 35 apple
lantar and the leica 35 summer crown
oppo were kind of announced at the same
time
so
there was no reverse engineering going
on in this this is basically just
voigtlander and leica just putting out
their variants out there and saying hey
here it is what do you guys think now
while i don't have a 35 summer crown
oppo lens to compare this with and
friends of mine who are like a
collectors here in singapore don't have
it yet either because due to um delays
and shipment and stock because it is
quite a limited lens right now
i'm just sort of relying on my
comparison with
this 50 f2 and of course you know other
lenses i've tried but i will say this
lens really really impresses me
and if you're not married to the leica
brand you're like look i've already got
a couple leica lenses i don't mind
getting something that's third party
save a little bit of money i'll get 95
of the you know the quality
you know what you got to try the
voigtlander guys you really do um i'm
gonna go on a limb and say this in terms
of the third-party lenses out there
right now not leica lenses but
third-party lenses for the leica mount
this is the best 35 i have tested thus
far
it is solid it is well built the image
quality out of it is fantastic
and the images i showed you
they're a prime example of it so
if you're on the fence
because it's not not a leica lens i
understand you but if you're open to
being a third-party lens owner
you got to pick this bad boy anyway guys
those are my thoughts on the voigtlander
35f2 oppo lantar let me know your
thoughts in the comments section below
is this the lens you're going gonna pick
up are you gonna pass on it i would love
to hear from you guys on that and also
can you like this video if you enjoy the
content and subscribe to us it helps out
the algorithm helps out our channel
quite a bit we're gonna do some really
cool stuff here and i can't wait to
share with you some of the really
interesting videos coming up in the
pipeline so with that guys take care
stay safe and i'll chat you the next one
bye
[Music]
you